Now suppose Bob wants to
access the printer HP1.
That is, Bob wants to send
a print job to the printer HP1.
His local host sends a ticket
granting service request to the KDC.
The request contains the ticket
granting ticket and a authenticator.
Which is the current
time stamp encrypted.
Using Bob's per day session key, SB.
When the KDC gets the request,
it can decrypt the TGT.
And it knows that it is a valid TGT.
Because only the KDC has the key
to properly encrypt the ID of Bob
contained in the TGT.
It then uses the key,
SB, contained in the TGT to verify
the authenticator by decrypting it.
And checking the time stamp is current.
This proves that the sender is Bob,
because only Bob has the key SB.
That can encrypt the current
time stamp properly.
The KDC then generates a ticket for
Bob to communicate with the printer.
This ticket contains
a session key KBP and
Bob's ID and its encrypted
using the printer's master key.
Note that a network device such
as a printer has a long and
random master key configured in.
And it's typically hard to guess or
crack.
Therefore, the tickets for these devices
are encrypted using their master keys.
The KDC sends a ticket granting
service response to Bob's local host.
It contains a session key KBP.
The ID of Bob and
the ticket to the printer and
it is encrypted using
Bob's private key Sb.
Therefore, only Bob's local
station can decrypt this, and
verify that it is from the KDC.
Because only the KDC can decrypt the ID
of Bob correctly with the key SP.
Because the key sp is embedded in TGT
and only the KDC can decrypt the TGT.
Then Bob's local host can
authenticate itself to the printer.
It can send a message to
the printer containing the ticket.
The authentication request contains
the ticket and an authenticator.
The authenticator is the server text
of the current timestamp encrypted.
Using a share key between Bob's
local host and the printer.
When the printer gets the ticket,
it can decrypt the ticket using his
master key shared with the KDC.
Because the ticket was
created by the KDC.
And it was encrypted using the share
key between the printer and the KDC.
That is,
the printer can verify that the KBP
was created by the KDC,
to communicate with Bob's Local Host.
The print server can then use KBP
to verify the authenticator by
decrypting the server text and
verifying that the result matches
with the current time stamp.
It then sends a response to
authenticate itself by say,
adding one to the current timestamp and
encrypt it.
Using the share key between
Bob's Local Host and the printer.
And after this, authentication steps,
then Bob's Local Host can send
a print drop to the printer.